[Music]
time again Wednesday and it's another
exciting episode of careless so you see
this big box right here right yeah that
big box brought that big boy right there
now this is a prop replica this is the
Infinity Gauntlet we're gonna dig into
this this is gonna be why why I decided
to do this let us first start off with
like following subscribe hit that like
button if this is your first time here I
want you to hit that like button so you
can continue to get all this great
content that's coming your way also go
to Lords of gaming dotnet where we give
you all up-to-date and current need to
be stuff that's video game news
entertainment news sports and also Kos
those collectibles that you love king of
the statues so if you go to the Lords of
gaming dotnet website and you go to the
left-hand tab and you hit the iron Lords
there is a whole bunch of mini menus
that will pop up for your viewing
entertainment now we are here for this
big boy we're gonna have for why people
call it wings this statue this prop
replica
the reason why I had to have it is after
I saw that masterful movie of infinity
war and I saw that gauntlet then I saw a
sideshow decided to do a prop replica of
the same gauntlet that was on a 1 to 1
ratio that was used in the movie I
needed to have it you see this love
affair that the audience is having now
with daños started with me a long time
ago before he even thought about giving
the gauntlet when he was only worried
about the Cosmic Cube and MCU is called
the tesseract we went over this already
so now you got this gauntlet that is a
monstrosity is what you've been
collecting your books for right I mean
let's be honest a lot of people got into
comic books or Marvel books at the
beginning of probably the infinity war
or the Infinity Gauntlet or Thanos quest
something that has to do with this
villain that United the cosmic universe
with the earth base arrows so these
heroes all became together because
usually you will get a story about us
you know like Seltzer for somebody here
and never actually melded it that you
know you felt like one big universe and
I thought that was a synergy that Marvel
movies the MCU did so well here they
took the disbelief of space and brought
it down to earth and it gave you a
reason to believe that something so
dangerous was in the hands of a madman
they call Thanos the mad Titan for a
reason because he believes in his
convictions and his convictions and MC
was overpopulation and he was cleansing
the universe with this plague so he used
an affinity gauntlet now let's get into
this gauntlet itself if you can see by
the pictures I am a large man I am six
foot four I wear size 13 shoe you see
this hand
ginormous that hand pales in comparison
to this monstrosity but a pitch as you
see here that's my hands what in sane
this is actually bigger than I imagined
I swear I did not expect it to be this
size and I'm going to put it next to my
Thanos on maquette so you can see the
difference or the size statue compared
you know the it is it is and it's heavy
this statue is heavy the dimensions will
be and loads of gaming dotnet and you
you can see the size and dimensions of
the statue which is insane this is one
of the most talked about pieces to come
from sideshow in years trust if you have
this and you have that Thanos and you
have the portrait I have a painting of
Thanos as well from sideshow that will
we will be unveiling soon you will get
all of that and you will see it all in
polish glory because he will have a
section you know he has done things in
the Marvel Universe that hasn't been
done from characters and he deserves
that
so this statue here will be one of the
focal points inside of my man cave this
this prop replica is by far the most
detailed prop replica that I've seen it
has electronic parts that show each gem
lights up you plug it into the wall so
the only downside is you need a socket
you know you need to actually be able to
be close to a socket to plug it in if
you want it to light up you can probably
get a portable battery pack to plug it
into the portable battery pack which I
will probably do and that way I don't
have to plug it into a socket because
it's a USB to USB so you just plug it
into the portable battery pack put it
right there let it shine when it runs
out recharge it put it right back up and
that way you don't have to worry about a
lot of things you know look at it
spinning it's beautiful this is the last
episode of Cal West before we go to e3
and this episode is very endearing and
near and dear to me because are going
into this in III Microsoft ahead of the
game of division of Xbox Phil Spencer
fell Dominus Spencer that's what we call
them it's forming the Infinity Gauntlet
and it's only fitting that this is the
last one right before the show I was
anticipating it I could not wait and I'm
glad that I was able to bring this to
you so again like following subscribe go
to Lords of gaming dotnet where you can
get all the new information and also
listen and watch to the last word with
loyal Cognito
andy von teese with all the ludus
shooter news with all our new destiny
stuff is going on you've got to be right
back and all the stuff with the vision
tool man loaded shooters is poppin
and Borderlands 3 is coming so these
guys will have all the up-to-date
information and you know Kos is here for
you so next week I will also have an
episode for you and you guys will love
that episode because I'm gonna delve
deep into your next character and that's
ahead so watch the video so you can see
all the wonderful pictures and you can
see this bad boy and all its glory
thank you again I do appreciate every
last one of you have a blessed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]